Call of Duty modern warfare's DMZ mode
is a Sandbox style extraction Royale
mode with a steep learning curve let's
call it escape from tarkov light and
trust me there are plenty of things I
bet you didn't know you could do there's
also some really cool rewards to chase
so if you want to hop in I've got some
rapid fire tips on how to improve your
game
DMZ is a mode where you need to have a
goal in mind if you know what you're
after you'll make your life a lot easier
just wandering around the map means
you're gonna have a bad time because the
AI are super angry like seriously think
of DMZ at first as a place to complete
faction missions I'm talking resource
farming exploding vehicles or snacking
kills with certain weapons check those
objectives off your list and get out of
there and you're good if you're like me
extracting after having accomplished
something is the way to go also don't be
afraid to extract early if you stumbled
on any good gear like a three-played
vest especially if your teammates look a
little scrubby this way you don't die
and lose your hard-earned rewards now
that's not to say you can't make things
low stakes and just mess around just be
sure to leave your good guns behind so
you don't lose them
if you're without a squad in DMZ use
your ping wheel and select the option to
ask people to join you you can in theory
fill your squad back up and just keep
going also keep a faction Mission around
you can activate three at a time which
you can do solo if you do find yourself
without a squad
strength in numbers is real especially
in difficult situations your odds of
surviving are greater with a strong
Squad so keep everyone healthy and well
stocked ping good items for your squad
or be a bro and grab some things they
need if they've got a full load be sure
to hand out ammo like it's candy
now if you find yourself alone and
outgunned with high-level players all
around there is a lesser-known way to
extract simply hit up a hostage Rescue
Mission and if you succeed a chopper
comes in to pick up the hostage that you
can also get on pretty clutch if you're
too far from a normal extraction late in
the game if you're feeling ballsy and
want some more action you can scoop some
gas masks from the helicopter and just
bail and head back to the battlefield
if there is one thing you need to do at
the start of every round it's focused on
getting a two to three plate armor vest
the AI does not play around they hit
hard and you'll be chewing through armor
constantly if you don't randomly find
armor vest the best way to do this is to
gather local junk keep an eye on the
price of that junk and then sell it at a
buy station if you don't have enough go
buy a key card to a local stronghold
where you'll usually find better gear if
you have a tough time the cave complex
is a safe bed for good items in my
experience keep in mind that in general
items in the game follow a sort of logic
for example you're likely to find
medical items in bathrooms
once you get a grasp on Faction missions
it is time to go for bigger rewards
there are a few big ones but be aware
that many of these rewards will vastly
increase the chance of you winding up in
more battle royale style PvP with other
players the first you'll notice each
round is when other players grab a
weapons case and get marked on the map
although you can grab and extract with
the weapons case a total of seven times
in my opinion the first and the last
rewards are the best the first
extraction gets you the barrier tape rpk
blueprint which is a very good weapon
for this mode packing a high capacity
drum magazine and incendiary rounds Plus
I mean just look at this thing the
seventh time you extract with the case
though is nice because you get this
really cool chemist skin the other huge
PVP reward in the game right now is to
head to a radiation Zone find the
chemist and extract with their m13b only
one person in your party gets the weapon
however players are reporting that if
you load back into a round with your
squad and the person with it drops it
for you at an extraction you can get it
without fighting the chemist again
now if you get the weapon case other
teams will come after you so make sure
you bring along the Speedy ride or a
chopper and then get to the nearest
extraction Point fast I saw some squads
roam around the map trying to confuse
other players which extraction point
that we're gonna use but this just gave
the server more time to chase them down
now this will vary based on your
preference but if you don't have a good
Contraband gun or blueprint with you at
the start of a round I recommend going
for an rpk these lmgs are high capacity
and great for PVE because you'll have
plenty of situations where you don't
have time to reload mid battle and you
need a lot of bullets
[Music]
you can always take equipment with you
into the DMZ for free take the ammo box
just just do it you don't want to run
out of ammo right and I mean come on do
I need to say more about this
[Music]
now you have protected slots that unlock
as you complete faction missions these
let you take a weapon from your regular
inventory into DMZ but if you die they
go into a lengthy two hour cooldown
period extracting successfully lowers
that cooldown and also there's another
way scattered around the maps are
dumpsters find one and deposit cash to
lower your cooldown timer
[Music]
just like in Warzone if you catch a
straggler from an enemy Squad and you
knock them rather than finishing them
off you can interrogate them to find
where their buddies are super Nifty and
worth the extra effort knowledge is
power am I right
you [ __ ] where are they
there are times when vehicles are key to
your survival in DMZ and they run out of
gas you can repair and refuel them at
gas stations however if you're in a bad
spot already and the enemy Presence at
gas stations might make this a no-go
fortunately a lot of gas stations have
gas cans that you can grab as long as
you're a passenger in a moving vehicle
you can go into your backpack and select
the gas can then refuel your vehicle at
any time
don't forget you can have another gun in
your medium or large backpack like if
you want a sniper rifle handy for later
on in matches you also get to keep these
as Contraband when you extract that
means if you're low on Contraband
weapons feel free to go in grab three
weapons and bail if you find the
Basilisk revolver at a police station
for example pack it for a later faction
mission where you need it for headshots
you can also just use your own basilisk
blueprint to complete that faction
Mission as a matter of fact while we're
on the subject DMZ is one of the best
ways to level guns in Modern Warfare 2.
extracting with a gun in DMZ will unlock
its base model across the entire game
if your squad gets overwhelmed and
downed by AI near a body of water be a
pal and crawl into deep water before
dying your squad can dive down and
revive you which is a much safer way to
do it than in the open side note you can
find loot underwater sometimes and I
mean if we're on the topic of saving
your squad the revive pistol is very
powerful it can not only revive at a
distance but comes with self-revive
a lot of missions and activities like
drilling safes and DMZ will call in
waves of enemies on Choppers and in
vehicles you do not need to sit around
waiting for them to attack you it can be
easier to shoot down the helicopters or
blow up Vehicles before the bad guys
ever get a chance to exit alternatively
if you think other players are around
you might want to leave baddies alive at
objectives or extraction points to slow
them down and give you a better Fighting
Chance the Armored Cars enemies show up
in are pretty good and you can steal
them
[Music]
so you asked me how to tell other
players apart well the short answer is
there isn't an easy answer once you play
a bunch of rounds of DMZ you start to
get a feel for what types of missions
other players show up at more often in
some matches you don't see any other
players and in some rounds you find
other squads at the very first
stronghold that you hit up if you hear a
lot of gunfire it's usually other
players taking on the AI the best thing
you can do is occasionally pause and
listen other players will also just move
differently like closing doors and
dolphin diving even though they
physically look different from the
enemies it can be hard to make out at a
distance other tails are if you pay
attention to the map the game will tell
you what objectives are being attacked
and if it's near you keep an eye on
Modern Warfare 2 has a ton of great
custom settings and although these
suggestions are not Universal here's
what you should consider doing swap
armor plate Behavior to apply all so it
only takes one long button press to load
all your armor plates if you are on
controller except plunging underwater to
plunge freely so you can escape quickly
underwater just by aiming down and set
parachute Auto deploy to off so you can
pull your shoot closer to the ground and
avoid getting shot out of the air swap
to automatic Sprint and also tactical
Sprint Behavior to single tap Sprint so
you walk or run based on how far you
hold the stick or the button down and
you only need to click once to tax frame
this lets you get to cover way more
quickly try interact reload Behavior
with prioritize reload so you can more
quickly loot items with a button press
but won't accidentally pick up items in
a gunfighter when you meant to reload
set controller button layout to Tactical
which will let you crouch while shooting
without taking your fingers off the
aiming stick
now stealth is very difficult in DMZ but
not impossible According to some Reddit
users if you pack a long range sniper
rifle with a suppressor and you don't
miss you can drop quite a few enemies
before the alert do make sure your aim
is true though the AI seems to have some
brains and can pinpoint you pretty fast
if alerted you can definitely pick up
stragglers using executions but it's
unclear if you need to pack a melee
Focus attack to stay quiet try using a
throwing knife also and remember in
stealth silence is deadly
it's important to remember you are not
safe when extracting and players can
jump on board at any time even as you
take off as mentioned before it's
honestly good to leave a few AI enemies
around the extract as an early warning
system alternatively players have
discovered you can jump on or hang off
the side of the helicopter to get out
with a slightly less chance of being
spotted by an enemy team already on
board
DMZ is shaping up to be a mode with a
lot of secrets so let us know what you
found that you wish you knew before
starting thanks for watching
foreign
[Music]